venezuela irá a elecciones regionales y
municipales en medio de una crisis
económica generalizada una
hiperinflación de 525 por ciento es el
principal problema de los ciudadanos
quienes además sufren por escasez de
agua combustible y fallas eléctricas
según la encuesta nacional de
condiciones de vida cuatro de cada cinco
venezolanos se encuentran en situación
de pobreza extrema es decir que viven
con menos de un dólar al día una
situación en la que la oposición culpa
del gobierno de nicolás maduro sin
embargo para el presidente venezolano el
principal culpable de la situación
actual del país es eeuu por aplicar
sanciones internacionales a su
administración sin tropiezos tres mil 82
cargos se elegirán este domingo en donde
más de 20 millones de electores están
convocados a votar 87 partidos políticos
participando en estas elecciones en una
cifra importante entre partidos
nacionales regionales y partidos
indígenas
hacía mucho tiempo que no habíamos man
tan alta concurrencia de los partidos lo
que le da legitimidad y mucho crédito a
este proceso entretanto la oposición se
prepara para ir a electoral sin unidad y
con una división que no logra superar
todos los partidos deberán haberse unido
todos juntos
para poder hacer una sola unión para
sumar votos pero no cada uno datos su
tarjeta independiente entonces yo creo
que no no no no está bien hecho no
permita que le roben la herramienta que
tiene para expresarse el voto vote como
protesta vote como castigo vote con
esperanza o vote con rabia pero voten y
vote por la unidad las autoridades
electorales esperan contar de nuevo con
la confianza de los electores ahora que
se ha vuelto a permitir la entrada de
300 observadores internacionales hecho
que no ocurría desde hace más de una
década para eeuu y el principal líder
opositor juan guaidó estas acciones no
son suficientes y han declarado que en
venezuela todavía no existen las
condiciones propicias para tener
resultados electorales confiables